Let's wait for Allah to answer that one
too. You want to wait for Allah to
answer that one?
>> Yeah. I want to quote a
>> before you quote. I'll let you quote. I
promise. But I wanted to ask you this
from the beginning. Every time you read
the hadith, you said Muhammad said,
>> we heard you right.
>> Translate the words.
>> I don't want to get in that. Okay.
>> I want to get in that, man.
>> No. No. You are going to keep me stuck
in there for an hour.
>> Okay, read your hadith. All right, go
ahead. Read your hadith. Let's see what
hadith you want to read.
>> Not hadith.
>> Oh,
>> I want to Jesus said in the Bible,
>> what did he say?
>> Why do you call me good? Only Allah is
good.
>> He didn't say Allah. Number one.
>> He said God. He didn't say father.
>> That's okay. But your Allah is not
[clears throat] the God that sent Jesus.
>> I I have proof. You know, you have no
proof because that same Jesus in that
same gospel says the God that's good is
the father. You accept him as your
father.
>> I mean every he didn't meant like
literally my father you know.
>> Yeah. Even metaphorically do you accept
that Allah is your spiritual father?
>> No.
>> So you just buried yourself again. Why
are you quoting Jesus when he says that
only God is good, but the God that's
good is the father of Jesus and all who
believe in Jesus. So why would you quote
that?
>> No, this was the perfect moment. Jesus
could have said, "Holy Spirit, me and
God, we three are good."
>> And who told you that? That question
meant he denied he's good. I mean, I'm
going to embarrass you with this, but
before I do, let's agree Jesus is not
good. Only God is good. But which God is
good? Which God is good?
>> He's not good.
>> No, no, I'm going with you. Okay. Only
God is good. Absolute sense. I get it.
I'm gonna agree with you. Which God is
absolutely good?
>> Which God?
>> The one God.
>> Who is he in that same gospel that you
read? Who does Jesus say he is?
>> You tell me.
>> Oh, I did tell you. I told you it's the
father. And which one you are you
quoting Mark or Matthew or Luke cuz all
three of them mention the same story cuz
I want to use that same gospel against
you. Which one you want me to go to?
>> Which whichever one I I
>> Okay. Most Muslims like to go with Mark
because Mark is the oldest. They say
it's the earliest one, right?
>> Go to that.
>> Okay. Here I want to show you who this
God is. [clears throat] That's
absolutely good. Okay. You ready?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Get ready now. Okay. Hold on.
Because now I'm going to bring it up.
Let me bring up all the passages. All
right, hold on one second.
All righty then. One second. All right,
let's show you. Let's see if you agree.
Okay, this is what you're referring to.
Mark 10:17:18. [clears throat]
Now as he was going out on the road, one
coming running knelt before him and
asked him, "Good teacher, what shall I
do that I may inherit into your life?"
So Jesus said to him, "Why do you call
me good? No one is good but one that is
God." Okay, I agree with you. Jesus
saying he's not God.
>> I agree with you. I'm not going to
debate you on that for now. I'll come
back and answer it. But here's what I
want to ask you. You ready?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. The God that he said is good. Mark
9:7, the chapter before. Okay. You
ready?
>> Okay.
>> All right. Let me show it to you. And a
cloud came and overshadowed them. And a
voice came out of the cloud, saying,
"This is my beloved son. Hear him." So
the God who's absolutely good says Jesus
is my son whom I love and you must
listen to him. So do you believe this?
>> Yeah. Doing that.
>> Oh wow. I want you to say it. So we have
to record it. Jesus is the son of God.
The son of Allah.
>> Every prophet is the son of God in
Muhammad. I want to record because I'm
going to use the Quran to bury you. Say
Muhammad is the son of Allah. The
beloved son of Allah. Say it.
No, I'm not going to say that. I know
>> because you just said every prophet is
the father to no one.
>> Say it again.
>> Allah is the father to no one.
>> So the God that Jesus said alone is good
is who? The father of Jesus whom he just
told the disciples, "This is my son whom
I love and you disciples listen to my
son." Do you accept that?
Do you accept it?
>> When it says son, you have to look at
what son means.
>> I don't care what it means. If you
accept it, then you're going to have to
say Muhammad is also the son of Allah in
whatever sense
cuz he said all the prophets.
>> Yeah.
>> So say Muhammad is the son of Allah
spiritually and Allah is the spiritual
father. Please say it. I want you record
it. I want to hear it.
Let me you know how Zak explains this.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Say it. Say Muhammad
is the son of Allah spiritually. Allah
is a spiritual father.
>> Nobody is son of Allah.
>> Say it again.
>> But wait, who is the one that Jesus said
is alone good? God the father. Right.
>> Yeah. Do you believe Allah the Father?
>> Why didn't he said at that time?
>> I'll show you what he said because you
misread it,
>> friend. He's going to bury you Jesus in
a minute because I'm going to read the
rest of it to show you what you didn't
quote. But I want to first have you
prove to me the Quran is a lie. So can
you say Allah father?
>> No, we can't.
>> No. Say Allah father.
>> Allah my Lord the greatest.
>> Say Allah the father. My father. Jesus's
father. Muhammad's father. Say it.
>> Jesus said, "Allah, worship Allah, my
Lord and your Lord."
>> Say, "Allah, my father, Muhammad's
father, Jesus's father."
>> I'm not going to say what you want.
>> Okay. So then, why did you quote Mark
10:18 when the God that Jesus is
referring to is the father and Allah of
the Quran is not the father. So if Mark
10 is 18 is right, then all of the Quran
is Satan. He's not the true God. Do you
agree?
If if what you're saying is true.
>> What do you mean? I just read the same
gospel you told me to read where you got
this from.
>> No, I'm saying if your Bible is
unchanged.
>> Okay. But you just quoted this corrupt
Bible to prove only God is good. So now
it's corrupt.
>> I'm not saying that. I'm just saying.
>> Okay. Did you not quote Did you not
quote you this Bible to show that Jesus
said only God is good? So then now it's
all of a sudden it's corrupt. So why'
you quote said you are not talking about
the story later.
>> Okay. No friend let let me help you work
through logic. You said to me Jesus said
only God is good
>> and that's the same gospel where Jesus
says that God who's good is my father.
Now you're telling me well maybe it's
corrupt. Well how do you know then Jesus
said only God is good. Maybe that's
corrupt too.
because I can understand that as a
Muslim. THAT STATEMENT THAT
>> OH, SO THE Muslim Quran, the Islamic
Quran is what you use to tell me which
part of the Bible you're going to
accept, which you'll reject. Well, I'm
going to reverse it. My Bible tells me
which parts of the Quran to accept,
which to reject. You're going to accept
that logic.
But Allah there in Allah make it clear
that oh Jews and Christians do not
exceed in your sayings.
>> Really the same Quran that says oh
people of the book do not exaggerate but
speak the truth of Allah the Messiah
Jesus son of Mary is only a messenger of
Allah and his word which he cast down to
Mary and a spirit from him which
actually proves my my dean
>> because I agree this the word of Allah
came down to Mary. Do you accept that
that Jesus was there with Allah as his
word and he came down as a spirit to
become flesh?
>> You see Allah is praising Jesus and
Allah is saying but he was a messenger.
There was messengers.
>> How many messengers? How many messengers
came down from Allah as Allah's word and
came down as a spirit to be born from a
woman. How many messengers? Can you name
me another one?
Every messenger has show me where the
Quran says the messengers are the word
of Allah that came down from Allah to
enter their mother's womb and they came
down as a spirit. Show me that.
>> I can't show you that directly, but
Allah says the likeness of Jesus is to
me the likeness of God.
>> You sure that you want to use that one?
Because okay, number one, it says Adam
was created from dust. Was Jesus created
from dust?
>> [clears throat]
>> But Allah before every creation
>> was Jesus created from dust. You still
didn't answer the question. See
>> yes.
>> You mean Jesus's mother's womb is dust.
It says his word which he cast down to
Mary not to the dust of the earth. So
was Jesus created from dust?
[clears throat]
>> Yes.
>> Can I try this again? Did it say his
word which he cast down to the dust or
his word which he cast down to Mary?
417. So you're saying your Quran is a
lie. I quoted your Quran and you're
disagreeing with your Quran. So I'm
going to ask you a third time. Did Jesus
come out of dust?
>> Oh, okay. Hear me out.
>> Okay. I'm waiting for you because I'm
going to quote the ayah again. 471.
Surah ayah 171. Jesus his word which he
cast down to Mary.
>> Yes, I agree with that 100%.
>> Did he come out of dust or from Mary?
>> From Mary.
>> Okay. And Adam was from where? From
dust.
That you just quoted the ayah. He's from
dust. Okay. Secondly, can you show me
where it says Adam is Allah's word which
he cast down to the dust?
But is it Allah saying we said to Adam
be and it is
>> and Allah didn't say to Adam be and it
is because if you go to chapter 38 7175
it says Allah created Adam from clay
breathe the spirit into him and ask the
angels to bow let me finish it let me
finish it and when said no then Allah
said you refuse to worship that which I
created with my hands
So where did Allah say be to Adam when
in 3875 he said I created Adam with my
hands. That's a contradiction. He didn't
say be to him. He created him with his
hands.
>> All right. You don't. Okay.